à l'image de la semaine dernière avec
emmanuel macron une nouvelle séquence
diplomatique a débuté ce matin cette
fois l'allemand olaf scholz qui est donc
à la manoeuvre le chancelier s'est
envolé tout à leur direction à kiev
juste avant de monter dans l'avion il a
exigé de moscou des signes immédiat des
escalades la russie où il doit se rendre
justement un demain virginie hertz
bonjour que faut-il attendre de ces deux
prochains rendez-vous alors déjà ça
permet de gagner du temps donc on est
dans le dialogue et dans la négociation
on n'est pas dans le temps du conflit et
de la guerre par ailleurs c'est aussi
l'occasion d'un éclaircissement de la
position allemande l'allemagne à qui on
reproche en tout cas les ukrainiens
beaucoup l'ambivalence pour ne pas dire
la complaisance vis-à-vis de moscou pour
plusieurs raisons d'abord l'allemagne a
refusé ou jusqu'à maintenant de vendre
des armes à l'ukraine elle a même
interdit aux pays bas est de vendre des
armes allemandes à l'ukraine cette
position ne devrait pas particulièrement
changé ça revient enfin c'est elle est
justifiée par une attitude de nizon anti
militariste du ha
au sud de la première et de la deuxième
guerre mondiale pardon ce qui pourrait
peut-être une petite réflexion peut être
sûr d du matériel de déminage ou bien
éventuellement des appels des appareils
de vision nocturne qui pourrait être
livré à l'ukraine est ce que pour autant
la confiance va être rétablie c'est la
grosse question ce qui va peut-être
établi un peu plus sa confiance et
l'aide économique qui devrait être
annoncé tout à l'heure jusqu'à
maintenant l'allemagne apparaît comme le
plus grand contributeur le plus grand
celui qui assiste le plus l'ukraine
économiquement 2 mignard dead 2 puis 2
puis 2014 depuis l'invasion de la crimée
500 millions d'euros de crédits le gros
point d'interrogation évidemment c'est
la position du chancelier allemand par
rapport au gazoduc north stream ii
jusqu'à maintenant c'était extrêmement
ambiguë aux etats-unis la semaine
dernière on se rappelle que le président
biden avait dit qu'il ne serait pas
opérationnel
enfin il n'entrerait pas en opération si
jamais il y avait une agression russe le
chancelier allemand n'avait rien dit
après il avait dit à peu près la même
chose mais pas en conférence de presse
devant dessinateur en petit comité et on
se pose vraiment encore des questions y
compris en allemagne et ce qui laisse
encore plus planer le doute c'est que
l'ancien chancelier spd social-démocrate
aussi schröder et lui à des fonctions
importantes au comité de direction
justement de nord stream alors ça ce
sont pour les tractations diplomatiques
et évidemment les enjeux bien concret en
attendant sur le terrain il est quand
même en train de se passer quelques
petites choses il ya des éléments qui me
disent que la tension elle s'accélère
alors militairement effectivement du
côté russe pas de signe de désescalade
pour le moment et effectivement 30 pays
au total maintenant ont demandé à leurs
ressortissants de quitter luttre
l'ukraine certains ont même demandé aux
familles des personnels diplomatiques de
partir voir aux diplomates l'ouest a
demandé à ses observateurs d'oiseaux
donc l'organisation de la sécurité et de
coopération en europe à ses diplomates
et à ses observateurs deux quitté
également l'est de l'ukraine quant aux
compagnies aériennes certaines
suspendent leurs vols vers l'ukraine ou
au dessus de l'espace aérien
l'ukrainien en raison des pressions des
assurances qui estime qu ça devient un
si peu trop risqué les etats unis
continuent à être extrêmement alarmiste
disent que ça peut enfin une agression
russe peut arriver à tout moment y
compris pendant la visite de du
chancelier allemand que ce soit à kiev
ou à moscou d'autres disent se sera pas
avant la fin des jeux olympiques à pékin
pour ne pas froisser l'allier chinois
donc c'est à dire dimanche 20 jeux
février ce qui est certain c'est que
depuis la fin de la gueule la guerre
froide jamais il n'y a eu autant de
tensions entre d'un côté les occidentaux
et les russes de l'autre